Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to talk about a language that partially descended from English,
but is not actually English.
The language is talk peace in an English based Creole language,
sometimes referred to as pigeon or pigeon English talk piecing is one of the
official languages of Papa new Guinea,
which is located in the Southwestern Pacific ocean, just North of Australia.
It's other official languages are English,
which is not spoken by most of the population and Hedy motive,
but talk piecing serves as the most common lingua franca and a lingua franca is
certainly useful in Papa new Guinea,
because it's the most linguistically diverse country on the planet.
Okay?
It's the most linguistically diverse country in the whole universe.
Over 800 languages are spoken in Papa, new Guinea,
a country of just around 8 million people with so much linguistic diversity
talk piece in is frequently used for communication between people of different
linguistic backgrounds. Look at the name of the language.
Talk peace in talk means language,
but it comes from the English word talk and also means talk speech, word,
message news, et cetera. The majority of talk in words, come from English,
but are used with different meanings or with a wider range of meanings.
This word peacing comes from pigeon,
but probably developed from the English word business, not in TOK,
but rather in a Chinese language talk. has also sometimes being called TOK.
Boy, boy comes from boy,
but actually refers to someone who was an indentured laborer, servant,
or slave of colonial Europeans because their bosses or masters referred to
them as boy talk,
began as a pigeon language on the plantations of German Samoa between 1880 and
1914.
When laborers from new Guinea were brought over an English based Creole in a
German territory. Why?
Well laborers from the Solomon Islands and from Vanuatu had already been working
on plantations in the Queensland colony in present day Australia.
And they had already developed an English based pigeon language
in short, they needed a common language for work.
So they adopted a small English vocabulary and use the grammar of their
Melanesian languages to connect the words together in this way.
A Melanesian English based pigeon language arose in Queensland.
Some of these pigeon speakers from Vanuatu and Solomon Islands later worked in
German Samoa alongside the new Guinea and laborers using their pigeon as a
lingua franca.
People from all of these places brought the pigeon language home with them,
where it became widely used as a lingua franca and became Creole lysed meaning
that it became spoken as a native language by some and became used for all
aspects of life.
Not only for the limited functions of the pigeon language till this day,
the forms of pigeon spoken in Papa, new Guinea.
The Solomon Islands in Vanuatu are all quite similar though.
They have definitely diverged into their own distinct varieties.
After pigeon languages become Creole languages.
They are technically no longer pigeon languages,
but they are still referred to as pigeon in all three countries.
Now let's examine top piece in and see what it's like vocabulary as
an English based Creole language talk piecing got most of its vocabulary from
English, but words of English origin are usually pronounced quite differently.
Following phonological rules inherited from Austronesian languages of Melanesia.
For example, brother is pronounced enough.
In a before B PL shark
suck, stand or stand up sun up
words.
Origin are also generally used differently than they are in English.
For example, from.
The English word place in TOK,
this means village or hometown area or.
Region from the English.
Word devil means soul shadow reflection or image.
Plus two from.
English close to means close to,
but also nearly or almost Chris months from the English word
Christmas. This means Christmas, but in talk,
your age is also measured in the number of Christmases you have been alive for.
For example, you got Hamas Christmas.
This means how old are you and me got 10 Christmas.
This means I'm 10 years old since talk PC and vocabulary stems
from a small English vocabulary.
Oftentimes one simple word is used to cover a whole set of synonyms in English
or a category of items. For.
Example, from English.
Got or have got this means to have, or to possess in TOK.
There's just this one.
Word clueless from English.
Cloths. This means clothes, but also blouse or dress cross.
This means angry or annoyed or cross in English.
Cross means mildly annoyed and many North Americans might be unfamiliar with
that word, but in talk,
it's the common word for all degrees of anger or annoyance
From English too much. This means very, or very much or greatly or too.
Much.
And some words have expanded beyond synonyms to cover a wider range of meanings.
Stop from English. Stop. This means to be located somewhere,
to remain, to stay,
to rest or to be in progress with this word,
it might be a bit harder to wrap your head around. It's different meanings.
If you stop somewhere, then you are there at that place. You are remaining.
There you are staying there. You are situated there. The meaning of,
to be in progress stems from the meaning of remaining because the action is
remaining in progress.
For example, Penn belong me stop long.
This means,
whereas my pen pen of me is located at what place
normal talk piece in vocabulary comes from English.
Some words come from German since Samoa was under German control and parts of
new Guinea were under German control. When new Guineans returned,
this means to remove or to get rid of this comes from German house,
meaning out this means rubber and comes from the German word,
gummy.
Musky. This.
Means it doesn't matter and comes from the German McNeese,
which means the same thing.
Some vocabulary comes from Malaysia because of contact with Bahasa Indonesia on
the Island of new Guinea and contact with regional Molay languages. So soup,
meaning milk. This comes from the Malaysian word, Susu.
Some words also come from Portuguese because of early Portuguese contact with
Melanesia as early as the 16th century. For example,
this means to know, to understand, to know how to, to be able to,
to be cognizant with,
or to be accustomed to this comes from Portuguese Saba,
which means to know Nini,
which means child or baby comes from Portuguese pecorino, which means little.
And there are also words from many Austronesian languages grammar.
While the vocabulary of talk PC PCN mainly comes from English.
The grammar largely reflects the Austronesian languages spoken by early pigeon
speakers on the plantations. Let's look at a few examples here and later,
we'll see more grammatical features in context, the predicate marker.
All third-person sentences contain a predicate marker E.
Plus [inaudible].
Village. Doesn't have any water word for word.
This sentence is village predicate, marker. No, have water.
The word he tells us that what comes next is the predicate.
The part of the sentence,
telling us something about the subject and normally contains a verb in the
language with a simple vocabulary and grammar.
It would be easy to hear the predicate as part of the subject.
If there were no predicate marker place,
no gut water could be understood as the village that doesn't have any water,
which would leave the listener waiting for a predicate to follow.
Because that whole phrase sounds like the subject next,
the trends of the verb. Marker. IM when verbs are transitive. In other words,
when they are followed by an object, the suffix IM is attached.
Me like in two months, BIA.
It means I really like beer.
I like really beer like him consists of like from
English, like with the trends that have suffix him.
[Inaudible].
This means yesterday, I saw you on the street yesterday.
I see you on street. Looking consists of look from English.
Look with the transit of suffix in the sentence.
Also contains an interesting word long, which brings me to the next point.
Prepositions talk basically has two main prepositions.
One of them is long, which comes from English along.
It's used to cover a wide range of English prepositions in by on with,
from two and at have a look at this exam.
All [inaudible] Monday longly.
This means they went by road on Monday to lay they preposition marker
go by road on Monday to lay that's the name of a
city. The word oil comes from English all,
but one of its uses is the third person, plural pronoun.
The other main preposition is belong, which comes from English belong.
It covers the meanings of, and for, and is often used to indicate possession.
For example.
[Inaudible].
This is my brother's car. This it predicate marker.
Car of brother of me next,
the adjective marker pillar.
The suffix pillar is normally added to single syllable adjectives when they
appear before nouns. So a big tree is big.
Bella DUI big comes from English big and then the adjective suffix is attached
to it. D Y is a word from one of TOK PCNs Austronesian substratum languages.
It's also worth pointing out that this phrase has no indefinite article talk.
PCN has no definite article and no indefinite article. In other words,
no equivalent of the or, but for clarity, one pillar,
meaning one can be used. So this phrase could.
Be one pillar, big pillar.
One big tree.
Notice that one pillar comes from the English word one with the adjective suffix
attached to it. Okay. We've seen some of its key features.
So now let's look at a couple more top PC in sentences and break them down.
Suppose me, plan. No, got enough money long by him.
House me Pella can walk him house the soul.
This means if we don't have enough money to buy a house,
we can just build a house word for word it's.
If we no have enough money to buy house,
we can build house just suppose comes from English suppose
and is used to mean if me Pella comes from English, me,
which on its own would mean. I,
but the suffix pillar indicates that it's the plural form we belong is
used here. To mean for, by him,
comes from English by and has the transitive verb.
Suffix Wakim comes from English work, but means to make,
build or repair tussle means just, or only, and comes from English.
That's all. And one more example.
And me being sparked, no go through long sing sing.
He got really drunk at the party, or she got really drunk at the party.
He or she predicate marker past tense marker. Be drunk badly.
Really at party M comes from English, him,
but as for both male and female and for subjects and objects in TOK piece in
bin comes from English bean and is used as an aspect marker to show completion
of an action effectively indicating past tense in this sentence,
the spark comes from English spark and means to be drunk.
No good comes from English. No good.
True comes from English true and is used as an adjective or as an adverb,
like truly or really long refers to the location of the action.
And syncing is a re-do application of the English word sing and is used to mean
sing or song,
but also for a ceremony involving dancing and singing or for a party.
Let's think about being again for a minute talk,
PCN verbs are basically not conjugated.
And the verb form is the same for all persons and numbers.
And times to indicate time, you can use a time word like us day,
meaning yesterday to Maura, et cetera.
Or you can use an auxiliary verb that shows aspect like bean,
which shows completion.
Another option is to place penis from English finish after the verb for
the future you can use, like, which has the sense of is about to,
for things a little farther in the future. You can use the word, buy or buy.
And by for example, by me, come back,
I shall return by and bind by come from the old fashioned English
expression by in, by meaning after a short time,
these words indicating an action's relation to time are not normally necessary.
If the time is clear from the context and the adverbs of the sentence.
Hopefully this video and the language samples within it have given you a sense
of what top piece in is like the English roots of much of its vocabulary are
obvious, but it's also quite obvious that talk is not English.
It's grammar is very different and even it's English based vocabulary is used
quite differently. Talk be seen as a language in its own, right?
It's used in the parliament of Papa, new Guinea in TV and radio broadcasts.
And it's used every day as a lingua franca throughout the country, though,
there are books written in talk piece in it's currently not used much as a
literary language though.
Some people think that it can and should fulfill that role as well.
But with English also being an official language and the language of schooling,
other people think that English alone should remain the formal and literary
language.
The question of the day to native speakers of talk PCN for some people,
it's hard to imagine how talk PCNs vocabulary is sufficient for all parts of
life. Do you find that talk is sufficient to say everything you want to say,
are there times when it's not? And for other people,
if you want to hear some more talk PCN,
I will put a link to a talk PC in news broadcast in the description below,
listen to that clip and let us know in the comments, what you think.
Can you understand any of it? Does it sound like English.
If you enjoyed this video,
be sure to check out Lang focus on the various social media platforms like
Facebook, YouTube, Instagram, and Twitter. And once again,
I want to say a special thanks to all of my supporters,
especially these ones right here on the screen.
There might talk to your Patrion supporters, many extra special,
thanks to them and to everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice day.